there was a period and it's been
interesting to see the pendulum swing
somewhat
so the silicon valley could do no wrong
for a long time where dc is connected
like oh you're like the innovators
you're the
super value creators and you're rich as
[ __ ] and you donate to my campaign so
let's just like
like leave you the heck alone and just
sing your praises every chance we get
and then that pendulum has swung because
of
uh like facebook screwing some things up
and and some other problems uh so now
everyone's starting to turn on a turn
towards them and be like wait a minute
like you know is this really been like
cool that amazon
is you know like uh so
one of the things that i think amazon
did wrong there you know a bunch of
things but like
there's diapers.com where they just
lost money on diapers for a while just
like for
diapers.com to sell to them like like
amazon did that sort of thing
just because i don't i i know about that
story correct me if i'm wrong
so they basically like diapers.com was a
popular website they're selling lots of
diapers
amazon lowered their price below that
to the point where they were losing
money just to put them out of business
and then they raise their prices back up
when they go on it's not cool
yeah i think that's so they go out of
business it was like they come to
diapers.com be like hey guys you guys
are awesome how about we
take over and then diapers.com is like
no and then amazon's like oh we'll see
about this
that they lowered prices to a point
where diapers.com was like
hemorrhaging money and then they were
like okay i guess we will sell to you
now
and then amazon's like that's what i
thought and then as soon as they buy
them then the prices go back up
that's that should be is that illegal um
that is illegal yes uh or it's illegal
in the in the sense that it's uh
anti-competitive behavior it's against
anti-trust law
um so so that sort of thing has been
coming out now
is something similar with and this was
like to me the biggest nonsense was when
uh mark zuckerberg uh was asked like hey
um
the people the founders of instagram are
worried that if they didn't sell to you
that you were going to
try and uh uh put them out of business
and now compete with them
go into destroy mode i think was that
what the terminal used
this destroy mode and then mark was like
no
i never would have done that like we all
know it's like like if instagram had
sold
to facebook you know there would have
been a freaking like instagram clone out
like that
uh and so so that this is
officially you know it violates
anti-trust law to do
certain anti-competitive things uh like
that
but the the reality is like of course
that you know if you're in that
industry like you're going to do
everything you can to try and
crush anyone who could potentially end
up taking your business
i think you have to assume
there's a lot of that going on we don't
know of with i mean any company that
gets to be that big you're looking at
the microsoft's you're looking at
the amazons you're looking at the
facebooks i mean
you can't i mean correct me if i'm wrong
can you get to be
that big of a company without anti-trust
violations without some competitive
behavior yeah
it would be difficult and the thing that
most people don't realize now
and this is one reason why i think
universe basic income so vital among
others
is that some of these companies have
essentially just like left
orbit in terms of business physics like
you think okay like i'm a company i need
to like
you know be ambition and treat my
workers well and like
sell sell things that are profit there
are some companies at this point just
like
like i'm worth a trillion dollars i
don't even need to make money nothing
matters like what's that you're like a
cool startup like i can buy you for 400
million dollars and everyone's rich and
i don't even care
like like they're just so unfathomably
big
that like that that like nothing applies
i think tim o'reilly called it like
super money
it's like at some point you just get
super money and then
like nothing matters and then we still
try and pretend
and what was funny is when they got
brought into congress like they pretend
too it's like oh we started in the
scrappy company they're like
they think it's like freaking at this
point they're almost like countries unto
themselves
like so they're just so staggeringly
enormously
wealthy and they have now at this point
their stock market valuations are
propped up
in so many ways that they can almost
do no wrong uh and
in that environment they're just going
to keep sucking up more and more
value like that the thing i kept saying
to folks on the trail was like look
amazon's worth a trillion bucks
paid zero in taxes soaking up 20 billion
dollars a year in commerce closing 30
percent of your stores and malls and
that was pre-crisis it's like
you know these this thing's like a black
hole so it's just going to just
suck more and more ballot and we're not
going to see anything coming out
um and you think it's like oh it's
because they're like out competing at
some point they just left orbit
and it and that the funny thing about
amazon is like they've been periods in
this past where it didn't even make
money
but at this point you look at it and
being like like there was a walmart
executive who complained
to me he said how can you compete
against a company that doesn't even need
to make money
this was walmart which is sort of ironic
because yeah walmart obviously like
crushed every
yeah like mom and pop retailer and it's
bad now he's complaining about amazon
that's beautiful but yeah like i joked
with the walmart folks it's like they
were like the
tanks that came to american communities
around the country just like ran over
every mom and pop
and then they were like we did it we
conquered america and then amazon's like
a
[ __ ] spaceship like hovering over
them it's like
we don't need to obey the laws of
gravity anymore they're like
walmart's looking up like what do we do
and then you have our government over
here and like that they're just like
you know the government doesn't
understand what is going on and just
looking up being like yeah like
amazon's a company like any other
that's like the it's it's yeah they have
their own
and i mean if you look at what's going
on with amazon like jeff bezos is so
rich
he bought the washington post with
essentially like pocket change from his
couch
like you know like the washington post
is a very very influential publication
that happens to be like the main
news source in our nation's capital like
do you think that
you know he literally and and he has
been relatively hands-off like he
has he doesn't go in and be like right
about this right about that but it is
it's telling it's that like amazon up
here
jeff bezos like you know up here and
then like
you know our nation's major media
like news source for our legislators was
like down here and he was like yeah
like sure he just like like took a
couple hundred million out of the couch
and just you know i mean he's worth at
this point hundreds of billions anyway
sorry no that was fascinating and i
think it under really
too i think that analogy of it's like
walmart came in with the tanks and but
they weren't thinking big enough and
amazon came in with the ufo spaceship
and just zapped them
i kept thinking about the video games
you play when you're like
you keep finishing and you replay it
again with all the upgrades
yeah just way stronger every time like
yeah
right i want to wrap this story because
it's to me it's interesting so the
founder one of the founders of
diapers.com was a guy named mark lore
so then amazon crushes diapers.com
absorbs them
marklor becomes rich but he's mad at
amazon
so he comes back for revenge years later
[Laughter]
and starts jet.com raises
i think you raised like like 500 million
dollars a billion dollars being like we
are going to out compete
amazon and e-commerce like he's like i
have found the way
okay and so then and so he got
all of these investors to pile into
jet.com
and then jet.com is like spinning do you
remember jet.com
no no no
jet.com they had i think their car was
purple they had like jet and some
smiling
anyway so jet.com spends hundreds of
millions trying to fight it out with
amazon
in e-commerce and then walmart buys
jet.com
as a way to try and make themselves
competitive against amazon
in e-commerce so so that's like the
how it all fit together it's like mark
laura came back for revenge
and then ended up like getting absorbed
by walmart in a
relatively futile attempt to try and
bring down the spaceship that's so
weird what ah that's so funny
i guess it never happened i mean walmart
failed to
to make it competitive it sounds like
yeah i don't think it's worked out
i mean like
walmart had to do something hold on
let's see if jet.com is still
i mean i hope not i just literally
literally redirected to walmart.com
yeah uh i think they paid a billion
dollars for jet.com
like if you look look up that were they
just thinking like look
we can't deal with another one of these
i just it was it was literally to try
and bring on mark lore
to be like the amazon killer because if
there was like any human
that represented like the diapers guy
yeah that felt like the david it was
like a lie there was this guy mark lore
and he had a chip on his shoulder
because he was like i'm back
i'm back you you destroyed my
diapers.com
spaceship and now i'm back with like
jet.com and anyway
i i found that story really
interesting in large part because mark
was so compelling that he raised
hundreds of millions of dollars
uh for an e-commerce company to try and
rival
amazon i thought that was like the most
amazing act of salesmanship i had ever
heard i was like
wow this guy must like be the most
convincing dude in the world
well they all they all got they all made
money it sounds like by the
by the end of it except walmart
i think that's correct yeah yeah that's
correct but i think it really underlies
this
issue of how can we possibly govern in
the face
of such super money if our regulators
and our elected officials
don't even understand they're not even
what they're looking at like their
understanding of what's going on at a
company like amazon
is so uh terrestrial if we're talking if
they're in outer space these guys are
you know on the ground every week i go
on amazon now i found
i find more and more creepy stuff like
at first they just had a few
like amazon basic items now it's like
every product that you look up
they already have an amazon brand that
makes it it's amazing
i just i don't know it creeps me out
yeah it's super weird they have they
have their own brand for literally
everything as my new as like a pen
a lighter to as big as like uh
well any clothing thing you would look
up like shopping products
every everything they have it they're a
machine
so what they do is they have this
marketplace and then they have this
giant data dashboard they figure out as
soon as like something's selling at this
turn level right they're like
they go and make it just they they go
and make it and so you have these horror
stories of this company being like
you know i sold on amazon i was happy
until one day like you know the their
competitor came and i couldn't get into
the search listings and now i
am dead and like they they're this giant
uh money machine that just comes in and
like it's a combination of like
endless resources and endless access to
us
and our needs and then endless data uh
like there's no there is no real
competition
um there's something like there's
something
that has changed about capitalism
um and and the problem is that we
pretend it's still like the 70s and 80s
like that there is like a genuine market
between firms when you have these
uh these companies that have just
reached unprecedented
scale size resources
and it's being facilitated by this new
version of
of the markets where there are certain
companies that just everyone's going to
pile into
because they're absorbing more and more
of the economy
it's like you you look up and just you
know you ask anyone it's like
um you know like like amazon apple
facebook
uh google would be the big ones where
you just look up and being like hey
you know if you close your eyes and open
them 10 years from now like do you think
those companies will still be
kicking ass and dominating like the
answer is yes unless
uh unless the government were to change
something for one of those companies
um and you're starting to see glimmers
of that
possibility uh because people
are starting to recognize some of the
extremes um
i i may be part of this conversation
moving forward too
uh oh jeff bezos just found his biggest
worst enemy
it's not mark laura
in closing i want to ask you one final
question
you have endorsed uh joe biden
tell me why do you think joe biden will
make a better president than donald
trump
joe biden would make a better president
than donald trump on many many levels
but the things i love about joe number
one he's actually a good dude who
cares about people and like wants wants
to do right by people
number two is he's really not very
ideological he's more of like a
pragmatist where he's like what are we
gonna do um
and as part of his pragmatism he's a
consensus seeker he tries to figure out
what the folks around him think is the
right approach and he's not going to be
someone being like no
screw you like i'm sure like the way to
go and it's not what you're saying like
he'll actually be like well if people
uh think that this is the way to go like
i'm into it
and then the third thing uh is was
something i said
um at the convention which is that joe
has this quality where anything he says
becomes the new reasonable
um like he came out with a two trillion
dollar green energy proposal
that could have been straight out of the
burnley or aoc like uh
playbook and if one of them had said it
people would have been like oh
like you know aggressive pie in the sky
and then joe says and everyone's like
yeah that's cool
that you can that that if
joe gets on board with something or
champions it then all of a sudden it
becomes the new mainstream
and so you have to ask yourself it's
like okay maybe i disagree with john
some stuff but it's like
what what's my preferred path trying to
convince joe that this is a good idea
or trying to convince donald trump that
he should you know
like adopted a complete completely
different approach to governance
uh and yeah i mean that that to me is a
no-brainer
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]
you